very few of our nation's attorneys are
hispanic latinos make up less than five
percent of attorneys while making up 18
and a half percent of our population the
annual undelay 5k is trying to change
that statistic and we have some pictures
from last year at some point but first
let's talk to hector mejia who is live
near sunset park with details on this
fundraising event to try and help latino
students get to law school hector good
morning
hey there john good morning we made it
to sunset park we've walked across the
street you guys have been watching the
group here stretching training all
morning along and now they're about to
go and uh show us you know as they get
ready for the analytic 5k a big mission
they're supporting here the money raised
next month it happens on september the
18th where that money will go to help
students pay for law school admission
prep courses joining us live we have
north las vegas police chief pam ojeda
to talk to us about why are you involved
and this will be your second time
running the underlay 5k good morning to
you good morning hector thanks for
having us yeah this is my second year to
run the underlay 5k
last year it was virtual so i'm really
excited to do this year where it's going
to be in person with hopefully hundreds
and hundreds of runners to raise money
for this great cause tell us as police
chief why is it important for you to be
involved well i think it's very
important for police to be involved in
their community in other ways to support
the community especially in such a great
thing like this that's going to raise
money for the latinos for their
education and pursue their dreams of
in-law
career enough law and how do you think
you know supporting the mission will
benefit not just everyone but
specifically law enforcement agencies
not just here in the valley but just all
across the board well again i think it's
great that they can further their
education and i think it'll be great
that they understand law a little bit
better and then they can see how they
can work with us and bring that back to
other members of their community and
just build the ground build together it
brings the whole community together so
the group is still going
yeah registration is open uh tell us you
were part of it last year when it was
virtual because of coveted reasons tell
us as you get ready for this time around
you've been running for how long oh like
25 years i've been running so a 5k for
you will be a piece of cake it'll be my
practice run hopefully yes all right
thank you very much for joining us so
registration is open the race or you can
actually walk it too absolutely or if
you're inclined you can also dance
the whole you know 3.1 miles but
registration is open the race or run or
walk or dance is on september the 18th
we'll be posting all the details on our
website eightnewsnow.com i'll let you
guys know i'll let you guys go but later
on this hour we'll introduce you to a
scholarship recipient and talk a bit
more about the huge mission and why this
is so important for us here in the
valley not just here in the valley but
really all across the board we'll have
that later on this hour for now
reporting live hector mejia eight news
now back to you guys and hopefully at
some point hector you'll be joining them
running so they're not just running all
by themselves we want to see make sure
you're getting your exercise in as well
thanks again
we'll see yeah yeah yeah